[Music]
a scientific journal just published a
brand new study
showing findings from human fossil
genomes that support the conclusion
that native americans may have
originated from china
whoa [ __ ] well that's the
that's the theory right they came over
the bering strait from russia which is
connected to china but then um if it's
ancient dna too like the current people
in china today which are like han
chinese it's different because like
there's been multiple waves of migration
so they could have originated there and
then that could have been the first wave
and then the second wave might have came
in and then just wiped out the original
chinese people too
because that's happened to multiple
times in um history yeah i think that
article what they're doing is you know
how like anything asian that you say
it's chinese yeah so like because
originally it's usually koreans that
came over because where those indians
are from the native americans are from
is this area in mongolia where koreans
also came from
so we're actually the original settlers
oh sorry no way no way i just knew that
the koreans yeah what was your proof
dude we have to we have to see this here
i have seen a lot of native american
tribes where they bury cabbage in the
ground and stuff that's what i'm saying
stars
all the indian casinos filled with
koreans that's true they're just trying
to get with their roots yeah and that's
true just wanna let you guys know don't
don't let them bastardize our culture
guys the korean culture yeah a lot of
indians doing this indian native
americans
but and then so so then now like what do
we do with that info not to say that
that's like this but we're like what now
now you got that what do you do from
there what did people think before i'll
tell you what china will do china will
try to slowly overtake
america
but
redemption is going to have their
premiere there
but you know that's what china's doing
with like um asia right now theater's
just gonna be a theater theater yeah
it's just a man theater
china um what they did is they justify
taking over tibet by saying oh they're
chinese they're a part of us oh that's
what they did that's crazy yeah so then
like anything they can do in history to
be like oh yeah that's supposed to be
our land like ancient china that would
suck if they use this holy [ __ ] chinese
propaganda dude
no the people that did this uh study are
not chinese
can we figure this out a chinese person
no jane nam wrote the article oh she's
that's korean name is korean or
vietnamese right or vietnamese yeah but
pretty much chinese
yeah because they'll say cause you know
so china's in that aren't they doing
that to your country they're slowly
taking over your philippines like a one
island by lit means people take turns
with the philippines it's getting pretty
tiresome everyone's kind of yeah that is
in philippines is like
half mexicans and half whatever was left
over in asia
mexicans
i feel like that's what's happening on
his head right now it's like this this
hair dude right here
happy mexican and then what else
whatever else is going on
yes in the back
yeah philippines that's that's
complicated the place that's that easily
like taken over through the years it's
like you know because you have so many
islands it's hard to i mean
i don't know what it is so many of its
own like indigenous people because of
the islands too right different
languages
do so much [ __ ] internal [ __ ] at
the same time that you know like
pacquiao you're a senator
because you play basketball he's
arguably not a good politician either i
mean like really it's that surprise he's
a boxer exactly though but like you know
like philippines has had so much
internal corruption that that's the best
time to strike for anything exterior i
heard duarte um
cut out a lot of that duterte detect the
dark tank
i thought that his war on drugs which
was basically you should anybody kill
anyone with drugs you gotta drag [ __ ]
you in my head i was like oh that sounds
kind of effective but no they said
people still [ __ ] deal used like it
didn't really do the difference that he
says it did oh of course because news
flash criminals never believe they're
gonna get caught yeah so it doesn't
matter what the punishment is also a lot
of people that weren't doing drugs at
all and they're dealing different
they're not sitting still anymore
they're kind of just like doing it so
yeah so for eight we got six bucks we're
here and we go
okay
yeah it's like one of those things where
like you know the people just a lot of
innocent people died too because uh the
cops could uh indiscriminately shoot
people and just be like oh that guy had
drugs
like i don't like him you know why
because his daughters are being used
so i'm gonna kill him because he's a
drug dealer again i wasn't there that's
just the [ __ ] news from my family and
[ __ ] but yeah what i heard is that uh
people that were in real estate like
they they enjoy that um political
party's reign because they make sure
that the corruption was out of it and
they're like no one's gonna [ __ ] with my
house
apparently i don't know this is rumors
right you know like we go based off of
rumors because we're human beings but
then like um when i think about
countries that are like [ __ ] up with
corruption i'm like sometimes
maybe they need a dictator
you know you can't just because even
like like maybe you know like yeah
we don't know what maybe once there's
order and structure then the dictator
can go yeah like someone's got to
establish
that kind of like everybody's following
the rules
and then
they can have a democracy it's a little
bit dicey too because like what country
isn't corrupt but
there's levels of corruption that are
still somewhat beneficial to the country
in an illusionary way and then there's
some that are just totally tanking the
country a solid dictator would be uh
nick cannon yeah
i was trying to find a way to get him
back
you know
he's really big on branding he's always
going to add nick or incredible to his
stuff you don't say it i want to see a
rap battle go down when they have
disputes and [ __ ] you know like a roast
battle
yeah you know tim de la ghetto's the
[ __ ] judge and [ __ ] like damn let's
make this country incredible again
yeah so cause sometimes the criminal
element does help
you know like original las vegas total
criminal element
you had 299 399 prime rib dinners yep
fire now the corporations took over you
have you know 30 99 prime rib dinners
and no free parking no free parking no
free parking yeah
yeah i don't know if this study
necessarily is gonna really change
anything other than get a bunch of
people going fanny true
yeah i know someone in china's like dude
let's just take america i know
i mean they're already kind of in the
process they're doing it for the red
they're gonna take alaska over first
because it's closer
but again i mean china china's activity
with how much of america they're taking
over again can't really be that mad at
china because they can't buy nothing
that ain't for sale
that's true but but you know when i
think about native americans and who
they might look like the most
i would say cambodian
there's a pageant
i would say like who looks the most
chippewa
chippewa
like it's cambodian right get a cherokee
man
or a chumash man you know and then what
does he look like the most to you and
i'm like
maybe a cambodian guy
but not the chinese cambodian guy you
know what i mean didn't one of you guys
say there was like a thing where there
was like a mongolian traditional oh yeah
i watched a
native american next show yeah it was a
uh it was like a throat singing
collaboration it was a mongolian throat
singer and a native american one and
then when they stood next to each other
i mean i can't even tell which one's
asian which one they're
know why you guys keep changing this
basket you're not wearing makeup though
oh okay that's different
[Laughter]
do you agree that koreans are the number
one asian in all the planet um in all
the planet as opposed to like half the
planet or um
yeah i mean for me asians there's big
three it's the big three
no everyone matters it's chinese
japanese korean like i mean because but
who's number one out of the three
clearly korean
all right take your case at home at home
your guys's home what kind of tvs do you
guys have hanging on your walls chinese
stevie's you have chinese clearly no one
watches tv in your house the tv is
broken your tv
your tv is this thick it's like this
thick you have to scream the triangle
turns on half the time that's the thing
that supports it just your tv brand oh
no no also when you wash your clothes
you know
number one i got a lg washer there you
go number one boy group in the world bts
number one girl group in the world uh
blackpink
blackpink is the number most subscribed
to uh account on youtube they beat
justin bieber you guys do have the best
groups by far yeah you're right you're
winning the silver continues walter
[Laughter]
the god
yeah uh you know and let's see oh um i
don't know
korean bbq
that is unanimously like that is a great
did you miss that when you've moved back
to usa
have you met anybody that doesn't like
korean barbecue you need to kill them
yeah you just spit on their face right
vegans maybe even if you even if you
think of the idea where you're like i
gotta cook my own food what you're like
no no no it's not even like that yeah
yeah you know what's crazy is like so i
was looking i just went down this rabbit
hole like how much each country in asia
their population and all that right so
korea
a third of their population of
ethnically koreans are actually outside
of korea yeah like us australia canada
whatever that's a ton right and then the
population in south korea is actually
pretty small compared to all the other
nations and how much noise they can make
for such a small group right yeah
because i was like looking at southeast
asia and vietnam has like double or more
population and i'm like how is that even
possible they're probably lazy or
something maybe vietnamese pop more kids
out i don't know like but it's also
called they call it korean diaspora
which is they spread everyone out like
so like globally there's there's no
country in the world where you won't
find korean people
are really really good at like keeping
everything in the community and growing
like financially because they're like
jewish yeah they're really [ __ ] good
at that man like dude
they're like alcoholic jewish
there might be some uh you know some
water to your theory dude i think this
might be true how do you feel about that
bart
i thinking you know like uh chappelle he
has that one bit right it was like on an
airplane and then it was about to go
down and then it was him and the other
black person was from africa and even
though they're not
like of the same
but he could like
my brother right yeah i feel like for
koreans if they notice another korean
they also have the
chinese people it's just like are
chinese are you cool
over there
dude
dude kp is real kids also have the like
oh i'm korean
instant connection dude you know who has
that who has a heavy puerto ricans yo oh
yeah oh
puerto ricans but you see the flag it's
the deflect you it's one of those like
you showed where the flag is you know
what i mean like as a as a puerto rican
i got it wow it's just one of those
things you just have to have and you're
just like
oh and it has the it's the thing it's
the whole situation same thing with
dominic is like oh i'm dominic and i go
me too
yeah yeah you just flipped that you got
it
you get the puerto rican dominican it's
the best conversation it's a wallet dude
so it's a cool little conversation
starter but yeah it was crazy that they
they all beef with each other like in
mexicans too because i'm all three
puerto rican dominican in mexico so if
there's a grand war which one do you
side with oh [ __ ] man oh mexico yeah the
ultimate i'm not even mexico and i cyber
mexico i'm more mexican than puerto
ricans my mom's full mexican my dad is
half puerto rican and culturally
with mexican like culturally i was
actually raised uh on the puerto rican
side my grandmother yeah that's what my
family my grandfather's dominican um but
heavily on the puerto rican side for
sure so you just eat bananas for no
reason and [ __ ] the bananas and
everything like that
is for no reason
not even rice just give me a plate of
bananas
hell yeah yeah we mash them we fry them
you know saying bacon yeah yeah
[Music]
you